[Música]
a
escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís en emisión
de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español américa latina y el caribe es
la región más afectada del mundo por el
impacto del coronavirus pese al inicio
de un modesto proceso de recuperación
para avanzar hacia una nueva etapa de
desarrollo es indispensable crear un
nuevo contrato social esa es la
principal conclusión del informe
perspectivas económicas de américa
latina- 2021 elaborada por el centro de
desarrollo de los cede la comisión
económica para américa latina cepal y el
café banco de desarrollo de américa
latina con el apoyo de la comisión
europea para hablar de la situación del
subcontinente y de sus desafíos
saludamos a sebastián nieto jefe de la
unidad américa latina y el caribe del
centro de desarrollo de los de
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económico bienvenido
sebastián muchas gracias durable un
placer tenerlo con nosotros
el informe que ustedes presentan habla
de una situación bastante crítica
viviendo en américa latina' es como si
tuviéramos frente a nosotros un cuerpo y
un enfermo que se ha visto todavía más
debilitado por causa de la pabic
efectivamente la crisis del cógido ha
afectado américa latina' más que otra
región en el mundo estamos hablando de
un retroceso en los niveles de pib per
cápita donde solamente esperamos hasta
2023 2024 llegar a los niveles que
teníamos antes de la pandemia y donde
estamos hablando de más de 20 millones
de personas que han caído en la pobreza
entonces un retroceso a nivel de
ingresos pero también a nivel social ha
sido un choque asimétrico afectando
sobre todo a las poblaciones más
vulnerables
el informe que ustedes han elaborado
lleva por título avanzando juntos hacia
una mejor recuperación no obstante
ustedes plantean una serie de
vulnerabilidades que existen
vulnerabilidades de carácter estructural
baja productividad problemas de riesgo
con el cambio climático problemas de
bajos salarios aumento de pobreza de las
desigualdades
si primero el título porque avanzando
juntos avanzando juntos a nivel
internacional
es importante como lo mencionaba que es
un informe en conjunto de diferentes
organismos la unión europea la caf banco
de desarrollo américa latina la cepal la
comisión económica para américa latina
el caribe de las naciones unidas y por
supuesto la 12 de ir juntos es necesario
en esta agenda que pensamos tiene que
ser multilateral para responder a la
crisis y segundo también juntos a nivel
nacional buscando acuerdos importantes
para una agenda muy
complicada porque necesitamos mejorar el
crecimiento inclusivo en américa latina
donde sin duda alguna pues estamos
viendo una recuperación leve este año
pero todavía no estamos llegando a los
niveles pre pandemia y para lo cual se
necesita una agenda totalmente
multidimensional teniendo en cuenta una
estrategia productiva de generación de
empleo también como buscamos mejores
sistemas de protección social
y finalmente como el aparato fiscal
puede ayudar a generar el empleo que se
quiere y la competitividad inclusiva que
necesita américa latina' usted es
referencia precisamente a todas estas
organismos agencias que han participado
en la elaboración de este leo 2021 leo
por sus siglas en inglés no obstante no
es la primera vez que tanto la ocde como
los otros organismos hacen
recomendaciones de carácter radical
respecto a américa latina para que haya
un vamos a llamarle un golpe de timón
una reconversión una nueva política que
es lo que bloquea precisamente la
aplicación de políticas más de más
orientadas hacia el desarrollo en
américa latina' sebastianito bueno en
varios países de américa latina se ha
visto desde el ejecutivo unas muy buenas
intenciones pero donde hay que tener en
cuenta la economía política de cómo se
va al congreso como este congreso está
polarizado muchas veces y donde también
una captura del estado donde afecta
precisamente pasar esas reformas que son
necesarias insistimos mucho en el
informe hay todo un capítulo sobre la
economía política de la reforma y como
por ejemplo algunos grupos
lobbistas en algunos casos impiden pasar
estas reformas que como digo en muchos
países existe la buena intención de
efectivo pero se atraviesan diferentes
etapas en las cuales son muy difíciles
de llevar a cabo en lo que ustedes
llaman la debilidad institucional sería
eso hay una debilidad institucional
estamos hablando de una trampa
institucional en américa latina donde
sin duda alguna necesitamos generar
mayor credibilidad unos estados también
más inclusivos donde también tiene que
llevarse a mayor innovación como nos
acercamos más a la ciudadanía y donde
estamos hablando no solamente ejecutivo
sino del aparato institucional que está
detrás de las reformas de un país hay
una cosa que ha llamado mucho mi
atención porque claro ustedes lo que
plantean como propuestas para ir hacia
adelante es avanzar a un nuevo contrato
social
y aplicar esto pero hay un tema que creo
que vale la pena detenernos y es el tema
de la educación precisamente y una de
las cuestiones que resaltan de este
informe perspectivas económicas es que
durante el periodo de la pandemia
américa latina es el continente el
subconsciente que más paro las clases de
todo el mundo 70 por ciento más que
respecto a los países de américa latina
esto trae consecuencias a todos los
niveles por la falta de conectividad por
la pobreza en las mujeres o sea es
realmente preocupante esta situación
efectivamente lo que hemos visto durante
la pandemia es que el cierre de escuelas
fue un 70 por ciento mayor de lo que
tuvimos en los países de la ocde y ahí
lo que se ve es que son las poblaciones
nuevamente más vulnerables más afectadas
porque porque precisamente no hay una
conexión a internet necesaria en estas
familias segundo porque en las escuelas
donde estos estudiantes van no tienen
precisamente los mecanismos de
aprendizaje en línea y la formación de
los profesores para llevar esta
educación en línea entonces no escogió
totalmente desamparados
esas poblaciones la educación virtual
ahí es donde es un reto fundamental como
hay un nuevos apoyos y una asistencia
que se tiene que llevar a cabo no
solamente en el corto plazo por el
mediano plazo a estas familias para
recobrar los años perdidos que vamos a
tener de educación porque la el impacto
que vamos a ver en calidad de la
educación en américa latina va a ser sin
precedentes sebastián en este contexto
preocupante de lo que está sucediendo el
conjunto de la región qué país se puede
decir que está haciendo bien las cosas
evolucionando hacia lo que podríamos
llamar una perspectiva precisamente de
ese contrato social nuevo contrato
social porque ustedes plantean una serie
de recomendaciones bueno hay diferentes
acciones positivas que se tomaron de un
ante la pandemia y esto hay que
reconocerlo a varios estados de américa
latina que por ejemplo actuar de una
forma rápida cubriendo a las poblaciones
que no tenían ningún tipo de asistencia
social o tampoco de protección social
está hablando sobre todas las
poblaciones vulnerables y ahí tenemos
ejemplos concretos como los auxilios de
emergencia que tuvimos en argentina o
chile también la política de ingreso
solidario en colombia o el bono familiar
universal en perú son medidas muy
bienvenidas donde se vio precisamente
cómo se puede cooperar con el sector
privado en lo que se podría llamar
perdón políticas contracíclicas en
cierta medida o no necesariamente fueron
políticas contracíclicas en el sentido
que fueron unas ayudas monetarias a
estas poblaciones vulnerables donde hubo
una caída importante los ingresos porque
son por definición vulnerables e
informales y también tuvimos algunas
agendas que se han ido más hacia
tendencias globales como la digital o la
verde en el caso de costa rica- la verde
digital en el caso de uruguay o colombia
que también son bienvenidas son
elementos de políticas muy importantes
del contrato social pero tal es el
proceso como en el caso de chile con la
nueva constitución ahora bien dentro de
este nuevo contrato dentro de estos
países que usted dice pudieron hacer
algunas propuestas puntuales no hablan
ustedes también para avanzar en la
consolidación de ese contrato social de
lo que le llaman desarrollo en
transición un concepto que fue acuñado
el informe perspectivas económicas del
2019 yo recuerdo que estamos en el
catorceavo informe de perspectivas de la
región que es esto precisamente de
desarrollo en transición de manera muy
resumida muy resumida desarrollo en
transición lo que insistimos mucho es
que tenemos que ir más allá del pib
tenemos que pensar en lo interno grupo
exacto tenemos que ir más allá de los
ingresos pensar en que el bienestar de
los ciudadanos necesita un enfoque
multidimensional donde por supuesto
están los ingresos pero también están
las políticas educativas de salud
también todo lo relacionado con el medio
ambiente como nos acercamos más a las
instituciones ese enfoque
multidimensional es fundamental donde al
final de cuentas nuestra variada el
objetivo de política pública debe ser el
bienestar de los ciudadanos para esto
dentro del enfoque de salud en
transición
insistimos también en qué forma
necesitamos una cooperación reforzada
una cooperación más aterrizada de
diálogos de pares de intercambio de
transferencias de intercambio de
conocimiento entre los países lo que
hemos visto con la pandemia es que
precisamente lastras de desarrollo para
ese enfoque multidimensional que tenemos
que responder se han ido agudizando por
el lado de la productividad sobre todo
las empresas más pequeñas las medianas y
pequeñas aparecen salido afectadas por
el lado social hemos visto ya no lo hago
hemos hablado un aumento de la pobreza
pero también de las desigualdades y por
el lado institucional pues hemos visto
también que la confianza sobre los
servicios públicos como puede ser en la
educación ha caído también en forma
general la confianza sobre los gobiernos
donde solamente el 40 por ciento de los
ciudadanos en américa latina' confían en
sus gobiernos ciertamente y el informe
al que estamos haciendo referencia
dedica varios capítulos precisamente a
esta situación a las protestas sociales
que ha habido a lo largo del continente
en el 2019 notablemente por ese
descontento de la población falta de
confianza en los gobiernos pero hay un
tema en el que me quisiera yo detener
también sebastián y tiene que ver con un
problema que afecta al conjunto de la
humanidad pero que ya se siente en
américa latina lo del cambio climático
ya este terreno ustedes plantean tres
elementos que me parece que son
importantes
precisamente se espera que para el 2030
por razón del cambio climático haya 5
millones más de desplazados al interior
de su continente latinoamericano delante
de ustedes una transición verde más
ecológica un crecimiento con nuevas
tecnologías nos puede de manera resumida
precisar algunos de estos elementos al
que va estar enfrentado el conjunto de
la población latinoamericana
tenemos que ver cómo aprovechamos al
máximo estas tendencias globales la
digital que fue de hecho el tema que
tratamos el año pasado en nuestro leo
2019 de cómo la transformación digital
puede ayudar a un desarrollo inclusivo
en segundo plano y todos los diálogos
que se han guiado en glasgow es la
agenda verte ahí
tenemos que saber cuál es la estrategia
necesaria para generar el empleo que
necesita américa latina esto es como
compaginamos están tendencias globales
con las necesidades locales necesidades
locales que insisto nuevamente una
américa latina de más de 50 por ciento
informal necesita generar los empleos
entonces frente a eso lo que insistimos
mucho en el informe es la estrategia
productiva que necesita américa latina
tiene que estar basada primero sobre una
mejor integración regional y hablamos de
algunos sectores específicos como
automotriz el farmacéutico y segundo
teniendo en cuenta como la agenda verde
puede generar empleo y la digital que si
no se hace nada perdemos 20 por ciento
de los empleos necesitamos entonces
tener una estructura bien definida de
apoyar a los trabajadores y no defender
simplemente los puestos de trabajo pues
ya saben ustedes los desafíos para el
continente son enormes para avanzar
hacia una etapa de desarrollo
de crecimiento llegamos ya al final de
esta escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecer a sebastián nieto jefe de la
unidad para américa latina y el caribe
de la osce de su presencia en esta
escala gracias sebastián por habernos
acompañado a ustedes les damos una nueva
cita aquí la próxima semana en otra
escala en parís
[Música]
[Aplausos]